not gonna lie to you totally counting
this as one of the halloween movie
reviews i don't know as halloween in the
title
uh it's a new movie so this should be
fun ish anyhow
this is the halloween movie review to
finish off this week of halloween movie
reviews you still get the altered beast
intro because
halloween
[Music]
huby halloween so huby halloween is an
adam sandler comedy on netflix which
usually i'd be like oh it's on netflix
because you know 2020 covid
all that but netflix is pretty much
where adam sandler releases comedies now
so
business as usual for adam samuel so in
huby halloween
adam sandler plays the town idiot in
salem
of salem witch trials fame of course he
plays the idiot who who's he gonna play
was gonna play the town genius doctor
rocket scientist no
he's the self-proclaimed town security
guy but not officially
any form of securities the security of
that obnoxious hoa variety and that's
hubie and hubie halloween he gets no
respect but
things are starting to happen bad
sinister things so huby's gonna get to
the bottom of it and we're gonna have
ourselves a mystery a mystery comedy
which if you've been watching my channel
for a while i've said before in the past
i was a 90s adam sandler comedy fan and
then jack and jill kind of
broke me what can i say part of a piece
of me just broke in the inside
i was like oh i guess i'm past this now
though i've seen his 90s comedies like
billy madison happy gilmore wedding
singer those are the three
i've seen those recently enough to be
able to be like it's not just rose
tinted glasses whether it be they're
witty for their low brow humor or the
time management they are in the pocket
they're in the pocket and they're clever
and i appreciate
them and he'll be halloween not gonna
lie to you it's not as bad as i thought
it was gonna be i mean
is it comedy of the year i don't know it
might be top three how many comedies
have we had but the point is it's not
jack and jill violating it doesn't
violate the senses just the thought of
it i mean adam sandler is
an adam sandler-ish character yeah is
there a love interest that completely
doesn't make any sense that you don't
buy at all
yeah but there is a charming quality to
this movie and
i did chuckle in it there was one scene
admittedly it was stupid and i laughed
and that's rule number one with the
comedy
make me laugh and when he can hit that i
find joy in that because i'm like oh you
haven't completely lost that
it's in there somewhere just needs to be
watered and nurtured
but it is in there still i still see it
but that doesn't mean the movie doesn't
fall flat in a lot of other areas i mean
first of all time management at a point
i paused this movie i was like
oh my god we're we're only an hour and
15 minutes into it and the run
time on netflix is an hour 45 but it's
15 minutes of credit so it really is an
hour and a half of actual run time still
it felt like way longer than that it
felt like
an hour 40 at that point by the end some
of the gags do
line up to make sense but some things
were just thrown in here
because there are a couple of characters
that are just in this movie for the sake
of
being a red herring because it's like
they were like oh it's a mystery and
they had the script they were like
well we need a couple more suspects if
we actually want the audience to have
fun and try to guess who
all right well let's put a couple
characters in there they seemed pretty
major
and led to absolutely nothing and it
wouldn't sting so much if the characters
didn't seem more built up and didn't
seem as cool as they were but really
they were just
they were completely useless thrown in
for the sake of being thrown in
because why not i mean it's not every
day i run into such a massive waste of
time
such as a couple characters in this
movie but man this movie does it and in
true adam sandler happy madison fashion
this movie is packed with alums you have
your snl alums
you have your happy madison actor alums
you have your happy madison character
alums which
it's all about crossovers now right
leaving happy madison's doing it which
actually if he does do that and he
commits to crossing over
more character that could be kind of
cool i mean it would add some new flavor
to this whole thing at least his
comedies won't feel like
phoned in yearly ea madden game releases
or some [ __ ]
not as bad as i've seen not as bad as i
expected i'm not gonna go out of my way
to watch it again but there
is an endearing quality in this movie
has a good lesson about bullying by the
end for me i think this movie definitely
would have been better
if i were drunk yeah now it's a party
all right so huby halloween
have you seen it what did you think
about it it's on netflix now or what's
your favorite adam sandler comedy in the
past
i don't know 10 years let's make it hard
for you whatever it is whatever you
think comment below let me know and
thank you for sticking around this
week for the halloween movie review
extravaganza that's one week down
three weeks to go i was gonna do a
halloween movie on friday and then the
boys on saturday i just don't have that
time so i'm gonna do the boys on friday
and that will be that i'll see you back
on monday
after my video on friday for the boys so
i suppose i should have just said that
then
halloween am i right anyhow thank you if
you like what you've seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]
you